Speaker 1: Hey, David, why don't Republicans
focus on policy instead of culture war issues?
Wouldn't it be better for them electorally?
I don't know that it would be.
And the reason that I say that is it's not
clear to me that Republicans actually have
the support to win on the issues.
If what what was it that Donald Trump did
that prior Republicans didn't do that essentially
gave Trump the victory in 2016.
It was that he ran a campaign based on cultural
issues and personal attacks and fears about
communism, socialism, Hillary, et cetera,
where his voters didn't actually have to evaluate
policy and say, does the policy actually sound
good to me?
Some examples where the Republican Party,
if they were to run on policy, would have
a problem.
Abortion is still used to raise a lot of money
by Republican candidates.
But the truth is that the American public
is more in favor of abortion being legal in
most cases than it has at any time in the
Roe v. Wade era.
So if Republicans really made abortion a bigger
issue, it might not be so good for them.
If you look at the Republican perspective
on.
Taxation, when you really get down to it,
I've said a lot of bad things about the populist
movement and how they can bamboozle people,
but one of the things that the more populist
Republican base has gone towards is to be
more hostile to tax plans that are just good
for rich people.
Now, Trump still passed one that is mostly
that.
But because policy was so secondary and the
cultural issues were more important, Trump
was able to achieve an electorate that really
doesn't care very much what his policy is.
Most of the things he promised he was never
going to be able to do and it didn't even
matter.
No one actually held him accountable.
And ultimately, what brought Trump down was
his mishandling of the covid pandemic.
I maintain that if the covid pandemic hadn't
happened and because Trump mishandled it.
Right, there's the idea.
Well, Trump could have handled it well.
And one, yeah, Trump was not going to handle
it well.
If Trump didn't end up having to mishandle
covid, he almost certainly would have been
reelected.
And to me, when you say, why doesn't the Republican
Party run on policy, it seems to me it's actually
better for them electorally to run on.
These cultural issues were against critical
race theory.
Nobody can even define it.
These people barely know what it is, but it
gets so much oxygen.
Think about the coverage of critical race
theory on Fox News over the last three to
four months.
And then think of how it fires up the base
and it spreads.
I mean, these memes spread like wildfire.
Money is raised.
I'm coming out in opposition of critical race
theory and schools donate to me.
Imagine if the entire time it had been about
like tax policy, they would not have gotten
the attention that they did.
And so to me, it actually seems, you know,
same thing with we're against communism and
socialism.
Joe Biden's making us a communist nation.
You ask these people, what is communism?
They have no idea.
And this allows them to continue moving forward
without ever really having to be accountable
for bad policy by just not talking about policy.
I actually am increasingly of the mindset
that Republicans do better right now by talking
about the cultural issues than they do by
actually switching over to policy.
Check out my segment from earlier this week,
whether a culture war is even winnable, because
that's another factor that the left has to
consider.
But I don't think that I think it's disgusting
in terms of the debasement of American political
discussion that there's one party that doesn't
even pretend to care about policy that's really
bad for the country.
But I think it's probably, in a sense, the
better choice for the Republican Party in
terms of winning elections, because they have
a constituency that wants to just fight and
yell and scream and cheer about cultural issues.
And they don't really want to deal with policy
in any serious way.
That's why Trump won in 2016.
Were it not for covid, he would have won in
2020 as well.
Send me your thoughts if you disagree with
me.
I do want to hear from you.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Pakman dot com, get instant
access and we will see it at.